returning this morning from Brussels
later than expected the Prime Minister
now selling a brexit far later than she
intended not March 29th or two in the
30th that article 50 now extended out
until October the 31st to the quiet fury
of many Euroskeptics in her party prime
minister said a few weeks ago that she
wouldn't agree to any extension and now
we're getting quite a long one there we
are heading towards Halloween there is
some symbolism in that I think in the
Commons the PM adamant her triply
defeated deal could still pass and allow
the cancellation have now scheduled
European parliamentary elections next
month i profoundly believe that in this
unique situation where the house is
deadlocked it is incumbent on both front
benches to seek to work together to
deliver what the British people voted
for the Jeremy Corbyn who had not rocked
the boat ahead of the extension
negotiation didn't hold back now the
second extension in the space of a
fortnight represents not only a
diplomatic failure but it's another
milestone in the government's
mishandling of the entire brexit process
the two leaders met in private and
continued to negotiate but Euroskeptics
tonight even a vote on the extension
have had enough appreciate the anger
that an abject surrender last night has
generated across the country which she
resigned in the early hours after
another lengthy meeting with EU
counterparts the PM accepted the offer
of six months with the possibility of
leaving earlier if the deal is ratified
that was a compromise between most of
the eu27 wanting a longer delay and
France insisting on the end of June few
believed there's much certainty coming
from the UK extra this agreement we
preserves a well-functioning
of Ziya European Union
ie we fix a deal but back in the
comments today her own partners a DUP
hinting that their confidence and supply
deal will have to be renegotiated within
weeks but they're subject to review
after each part
recession we're prepared just to let
that go on indefinitely without a clear
plan from the prime minister the PM's
cabinet today loyal no deal remains a
possibility so of course because in the
end as we discovered there's always a
question mark about whether the European
Union will continue to extend the Prime
Minister has invited MPs to take the
Easter break to really ponder whether
they want to reject her withdrawal deal
for a fourth time and send the country
to those European parliamentary
elections next month but with October
the new deadline where is the urgency
for any of these MPs to have to
compromise
indeed Sky News has seen internal
Whitehall correspondence that shows the
top of the civil service telling their
counterparts to wind down no deal
planning because it cannot happen before
October so no deal off the agenda at
least for a few months but the Prime
Minister's attempts to pass a deal very
much still in play puzzle Islam Sky News